over 24 hours Russian President Vladimir
Putin faced the biggest threat to his
almost quarter Century rule there's been
a veneer around him for decades that
he's got absolute power that he's
totally in control and for the first
time we saw cracks emerging in that the
question is how deep does that fisher
now go you can imagine there'll be lots
of conversations going on behind the
scenes amongst the elite in the business
and the military establishment about
whether to continue to support Vladimir
Putin into re-election next year
the uprising has raised questions about
Putin's grip on power
the influence of hardliners and their
even more extreme view on the war in
Ukraine pregosian himself
called it a master class and how to
launch an invasion and compared his
march on Moscow to Russia's failed
attempt to take Kiev last year
it displayed chaos in the previously
tightly controlled leadership and fueled
fears of instability in the world's
biggest nuclear power
Wagner mercenary chief of Jenny
pregocian stunned the World by declaring
an uprising through a series of audio
messages on his telegram channel vowing
to punish Russia's military leaders
has been engaged in a long-running feud
with the Russian defense Ministry a feud
that has been unusually public in nature
so that Feud really blew into the open
earlier this month when the Russian
government required private armies and
mercenary groups to sign contracts with
the ministry of defense and that
threatened pregosian with losing control
over his Wagner mercenary group
he then decided to withdraw his forces
and he claimed that as he was
withdrawing his forces from Ukraine the
Russian military
bombed his Fighters and 33 Wagner
mercenaries were killed now we don't
have any proof that this actually
happened
but this is what set off his so-called
March for justice to Moscow
by early Saturday morning Wagner
Fighters had entered the Russian
southern city of rostov and Dawn and
claimed to be in charge of the city's
military sites a few hours later Putin
spoke for the first time since the
crisis erupted
this is probably the most overt display
we've seen so far in terms of a public
challenge to his authority because
really his stint in power has all been
about the idea that he's absolutely
utterly in control of all parts of
Russian Society
then the world watched as the rebels
appeared to face Little Resistance as
they moved rapidly in the direction of
Moscow
the capital reacted authorities deployed
armored vehicles around government
buildings and set up roadblocks and
sandbags in the surrounding region
it was quite stunning to see how quickly
he moved towards Moscow and with
apparent ease it must also have raised
concerns about whether Putin had total
control of his Security Services if this
convo was allowed to move again
unhindered with speed towards Moscow
abruptly as Wagner forces got within 125
miles of Moscow prigoshin called off the
Revolt saying he wanted to spare lives
Putin Ally president Alexander
lukashenka announced he brokered a deal
between Putin and pregocian
under its terms Wagner troops and their
Chief would face no charges and he could
Retreat to Belarus
so what that provided was potentially a
way to save face and a way out of this
crisis for pregosian to withdraw and
Vladimir Putin to defuse what was a
serious challenge to his leadership but
the deal around pregosian's withdrawal
remains very murky one notable thing is
that he was welcomed in many parts of
the country particularly the footage we
saw from rostov
what it points to is really just a sense
of fatigue about the war but also that
no one really joined him as he did this
march to Moscow I think there may have
been an expectation that he would gain
further support from Russian soldiers
and that maybe that this would spark
protests in other Russian cities and I
think that may have played into the fact
that he decided to turn back these
events have certain Russia's internal
security into question a worrying
Prospect for NATO given its nuclear
Arsenal after 16 months with little
success on the battlefield and now a
Ukrainian counter-offensive followed by
the Mutiny of his own forces Putin's
future may be in doubt the business and
politically have been rattled by this
war already you know many Russian
billionaires are already under sanctions
and have had their fortunes Frozen and I
think this only contributed further to
their nervousness about the state of
Russia and the stability of the country
Ukraine reveled in the in the glass in
Russia
some moisture
word the up
the up strengthen the hand of hardliners
with the Russia leaders once Invincible
or are shattered we see cracks emerging
I don't want to speculate on it but I
don't think we've seen the Final Act
well many people think that this is good
for Ukraine's counter-offensive that it
shows a sign of weakness there have been
some reports that Ukrainian forces have
made incremental territorial gains but
it's really unclear at this point the
alternative view is that actually
because of the weakness and the turmoil
in Russia that the Russian defense
Ministry and the Kremlin will decide to
strike back even harder and do something
out of the ordinary to distract from the
domestic political struggles
foreign